Okay, friend. Now, this is not
Streamyard where if you get loud and
insult This is not Streamyard where you
get loud and assaulted, I can just put
you in the background. So, I'll I'll
hang up on you if you don't respect the
rules. But,
>> all right,
>> dude. Can Why you keep wanting to
discuss with me? You already had
discussions with Christian Prince
>> because like you you're making me very
triggered when you lie about Islam.
>> Okay. So, see there you go with the
accusations.
>> You're one of the greatest like debaters
about Islam against Islam. No, you just
made a false education. You can accuse
me all you want. Prove it, man. You went
on 50 topics because you didn't finish
any one top because you kept jumping and
jumping and jumping.
>> So, you saying there are two things I
said? Go ahead, bring it up one at a
time. Have your Quran ready.
>> You said the Quran separates the angel
from the Holy Spirit.
>> Angels from the spirit. Yes.
>> So, therefore, Gabriel cannot be the
Holy Spirit. Is uh is Gabriel an angel?
>> Yes.
>> Show me from the Quran where it says
Gabriel's an angel.
>> Uh it's not in the Quran. It's in the
hadith.
>> Say it again.
>> It's in the hadith, not in the Quran.
>> Okay. Secondly, can you show me in the
Quran where angels are said to be
spirits?
>> No.
>> Okay. So, how do you accuse me of lying
when I said the Quran, listen to the
language, the Quran
distinguishes angels from the spirit?
And you just got recorded again by
admitting, look what you just said.
Nowhere does the Quran say Gabriel's an
angel and nowhere does the Quran say
angels are spirits.
>> Oh no, wait. Uh yeah, you're right.
You're right. Correct.
>> So why'd you accuse me of lying?
>> Because uh the Quran also separates uh
Gabriel from the angels
>> and from men and from Allah. So that
means you're left with Gabriel being a
genie. That's was my argument exactly.
Have you even listened and read my
articles, dude? Don't you know? I know
where you're going. It's chapter 2 verse
98 and 66 vers4. So, I'm even telling
you the verses that you're going to use
before you even raise them.
>> Okay. So, in 298, Allah, Gabriel,
Michael, angels, and human believers are
distinguished, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. That means if Gabriel is
distinguished from Michael and Gabriel's
distinguished from Allah and Gabriel's
distinguished from angels and humans,
that means he's not an angel. He's a
genie like Shan is a genie. So you're
left with the Quran making Gabriel from
the Quran a genie, but not an angel, not
a human, not Allah, and not Michael. So
now prove that Gabriel is not a genie
according to the Quran.
Okay?
>> No, prove it. Don't say Prove it.
Okay. The reason it separated Gabriel
and Michael from the angels is because
they are angels with high ranks.
>> Prove it.
>> Don't assume it. See, you're assuming.
Show me in your Quran, Michael and
Gabriel are high ranking angels.
>> Okay. Allah says, for example, in the
Quran, he created angels with two,
three, or four wings. But Gabriel has
600 wings.
>> Where does the Quran say has 600 wings?
You see, he did it again.
>> But why is sticking out of the Quran
only? Because the hadiths which come
hundreds of years later invent things
that contra the Quran because you just
said it. You just said the Quran in
chapter 35. It's what you're quoting,
right? Surah 35.
>> Yeah.
>> It says angels were created with how
many wings? Two, three or four.
>> Yeah.
>> Yet you just quoted a hadith which comes
later that says a Gabriel has 600 wings
which contradicts the Quran. Can you
show me anywhere in the Quran that says
angels have more than four wings?
The higher the task you've been given,
the bigger the creation.
>> Where does the Quran say that, dude?
>> Just like for example, the Quran says
that the angels that will carry the
throne of Allah will be
>> and the Quran does say that eight will
carry the the throne of Allah, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And you found them in the Quran. So, can
you show me in the Quran where it says
that Allah has created some angels with
more than four wings? Because the verse
you quoted, you didn't mention the
verse, but I'm going to mention the
verse for you. You're quoting chapter
35:1, right? Yeah.
>> Okay. There there your Quran says that
angels are either created with two
wings, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Or three wings or four wings, right?
>> Where does it say more than four?
>> It doesn't.
>> Okay. But the Quran does tell you there
are angels, eight in which that carry
the throne, right?
>> Yes.
>> So the Quran will mention all this, but
it failed to mention that Gabriel is an
angel with 600 wings.
The Quran does say that Muhammad saw
Gabriel on a clear horizon.
>> No, it doesn't. It doesn't say it was
Gabriel. It says one one who was mighty
in power. And some actually say it's
referring to him seeing Allah when
>> so the the the Quran also for example
separates the sun from the stars even
though the sun is a star.
>> The Quran doesn't know that. Why are you
reading modern science back into the
Quran?
>> Dude, are you understand? Do you
understand what you're doing?
>> You are coming from the 21st century
perspective
and understanding science from a modern
scientific perspective and reading that
that back in the Quran. Show me from the
Quran where the Quran says the sun is a
star.
>> Okay. Not
>> why you keep doing this, man. Why do you
keep making assumptions?
I mean, I'm just going by reality. You
know
>> what reality? I'm giving you the Quran,
which is real. Meaning, it's an actual
book that you actually can touch and
read. And I'm telling you where the
Quran says this, it doesn't say this.
Where does the Quran? It doesn't. And
then you accuse me of lying. Now, what
was the second point you wanted to make?
>> Uh, you said in chapter 17 verse 85, it
says that they are asking him about the
identity of the Holy Spirit.
>> Yeah. And I have the quotation from suti
that says and as well as
that says the holy spirit. You want me
to read that for you?
>> I mean can you just show me a sahaba
instead of scholarship?
>> Okay. Can you show me a sahaba from your
earliest sources that said it's the
human spirit.
uh
>> your earliest sources, not someone that
comes 700 years after Muhammad where
they add an explanatory note human
spirit because the Arabic and the
earliest
explanation of this verse doesn't say
human, it says.
>> So why don't you meet your own demand
that you're imposing on me?
>> There's a difference of opinion in
scholars, but I don't think you want to
go.
>> Oh, so good. You admit there's a
difference of opinion from scholars. So
now can you
>> I don't think you want to go to scholars
because they enammously agree that Jirel
is the Holy Spirit.
>> No actually I want to go to scholars to
show you what you just admitted. They
contradict each other. So that means
appealing to scholars doesn't prove your
point. So if we stay with the Quran show
me where that is an angel from the Quran
>> because Abbas said that the Jews said
that
>> what source from Ibn Abbas because there
are many sources that attribute
contradictory statements to Iban Abbas.
You and I both know that very well. Even
in the issue of Isaac and Ishmael. Let
me explain. Even Tabi mentions
narrations where some say that Abban
Abbas said it was Ismael. But then he
quotes others saying Iban Abbas said it
was Isaac. What are you talking about?
This is what I just said. Can you quote
the earliest
source
that explains 1785 as referring to human
spirits? That's what the Jews were
asking because the sources I'm quoting
say the Jews were asking about the Holy
Spirit.
>> Okay, prove it.
>> I You want me to give you the source?
Okay, here.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, here you go.
>> Show me a Sahaba saying what the Jews
said.
>> Show me a Sahabah that said Ar
is a human spirit from your earliest
source. Don't ask me to meet a demand
that you can't meet. Give me the
earliest source.
>> Ab said the Jews.
>> What source? You're not hearing me.
Who's quoting it? Earliest source that
quotes Abas not something comes 200
which source the
>> andari comes when
>> imagine the chain of narration
>> comes when the same that gives chains of
narrations that says it was but then the
same says here a different chains of
narration that says Abbas said it was
Isaac don't play that game with me
>> so do you have a a contradiction in this
specific
>> no I'm telling you go to the Quran I'm
going to ask you a final time this what
you did last somewhere hung up on you.
Show me in the Quran where
that they're asking they're asking about
from your Quran refers to the human
spirit when the phrase always refers to
the spirit sent down by Allah because
the Quran nowhere says humans have
spirits. Can you show me where it says
humans have spirits?
>> Didn't Muhammad say the angel blows the
in the human?
>> No, he didn't say angel blows anything
in the Quran. Show me.
>> No. in the
>> I'm going to hang up on you because I'm
going to ask you the f the question for
the fifth time. Then I'm going to hang
up on you.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Let me ask you a fifth time.
>> Okay.
>> Show me from the Quran
where
the spirit
is
used to refer to human spirits when is
always used to refer to that spirit that
comes down with angels. And show me in
the Quran where humans have spirits.
>> In the Quran.
>> Do I have to say it a six time, buddy?
>> Well, the the word
a soul is a That's
>> No, it's not. Soul is naps. Spirit is
>> the difference between literally
translates to self.
>> Okay. Well, show me in the Quran the
difference, not your opinion. I don't
care for opinion. You're not a prophet.
You're not a messenger. You're not a
scholar. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's go to
Arabic. Arabic linguist.
>> And Arabic linguists
define terms based on how terms are used
in a variety of sources. So they don't
just look to the Quran. I'm not about to
hang up because you're playing this game
again. Let me repeat it for the sixth
time. Show me from the Quran
what the difference is or what you're
trying to claim that the nef's soul is
the same as show me from the Quran where
humans are said to have spirits to have
a not just a and show me in the Quran
where
definite refers to the human spirit. See
this is now the seventh time I asked
you.
>> Okay. But the the word in the Quran is
referred to many things like
Allah calls
>> it's a spirit from him. Exactly. Which
means Jesus is no ordinary human being.
That's our point.
>> How? How?
>> Because can you show me a statement from
the Quran where prophets are said to be
a spirit from Allah?
>> Allah's emphasizing that she's just a
creation.
>> No, it doesn't. It didn't say a spirit
created by Allah. But he's emphasizing
that he's just part of his creation.
It's like
>> nowhere does the ayah you quoted saying
that Jesus was created says
his word which he sent down to Mary
spirit from him. That's not the language
of creation. That's the language of
pre-existence that Jesus existed with
Allah before he became flesh from the
virgin. So let me make it easy for you.
Show me where it says Adam where it says
Musa or Muhammad.
minu spirit from him
>> in you said pre-existed in chapter 7
verse 172 it says that we also
pre-existed
>> doesn't no it doesn't because it says no
yeah because I I know what you're
quoting you're quoting when it talks
about when he made the myth with the
seed of Adam that's not pre-existence
because you were in Adam's loins I'm not
talking about you descending from Adam
and existing in Adam's loins I'm talking
about pre-existence in the sense that
you come from above into the world. Do I
even have to explain that?
>> What do you mean above? Where you
getting this from?
>> Okay. Bye-bye, sir.
See, you're on tangents,